[Musique]
m
jetro et jonathan ont grandi à montréal
nord ils aiment leur ville
mais il rêve du jour où ils seront
traités comme monsieur et madame tout le
monde
cependant c'est quelque chose que nous
on vit tous les jours d'enfants venus
des arrestations illégales des fonds
jugement c'est un mix de tout nom
sorbonne plus les deux amis d'enfance
aux membres dévolu jeunes l'organisme
aide de jeunes adultes à se défendre
quand ils sont injustement interpellés
ou arrêter ce qui arrive aussi au père
de famille sans dossier criminel comme
monsieur désiré et brice marc moi je
voulais déjà voix pour m'arrêter souvent
mais là je l'avoué pas comme si j'avais
volé je lâche et trouvera mais bon eux
sur m'acheter un droit du log acheter
n'importe quoi 3 je suis plutôt surpris
par la police marais point de journée
vous vous êtes arrêté régulièrement au
filet au monde où dit des fois trois
fois par jour
faut pas exagérer zone alors j'ai besoin
n'auraient pas et pourquoi
mais parce que je suis noir cheveux gros
mais je porte une casquette ou
hollandaises pigeon leur camion roulait
en train de jouer au vert à montréal
nord attire les soupçons ne se brise pas
un travail comme cols bleus à la ville
de montréal depuis 20 ans il a appris à
ne pas réagir aux interpellations
multiples à ne pas poser de questions
quand nous embarquons avec lui
rapidement un policier se met à le
suivre
les origines
il faut pas nerveux monsieur brice ma
prépare ses papiers
trois rues plus loin la police 16 de
suivre mon cerveau malade et on connaît
franklin nous avons suivi deux policiers
qui patrouillent à montréal nord l'un
d'eux a déjà intercepté franklin brice
marc la façon dont il savait la fal le
véhicule qui conduit ça attire le regard
des policiers
parce qu'il ressemble aussi à un autre
individu qui est très inquiets très
connu dans notre secteur c'est policiers
ni faire du profilage racial ce soit car
l'horreur va peut-être plus remarqué
qu'un véhicule
guy hands acv les jeunes comme jetro et
jonathan sont encore plus souvent
interpellé le service de la police de
meaux rial ne tient pas de statistiques
sur ces interventions par ethnie ou par
as mais au rapport interne de 2007
indique qu à moriat nord cette année là
40% des jeunes hommes noirs avaient subi
au moins un contrôle d'identité
seulement 6% des jeunes blancs avaient
eu un tel contrôle
vous êtes mois on compte c'est un moyen
non le puissant ta question vous avez
vous a jamais vu vous arrêtez vous dire
airways pour vérification n'a vérifié
voulu savoir qui vous êtes
vous avez lu ce n'est pas trop c'est un
profilage vestimentaire profilage de
commandeur personne agit avec la police
je ne pense pas que systématiquement on
va les lois parce qu'il noie on va là
parce qu'il ya un contexte il ya un
appel où on voit quelque chose qui ne
tourne pas rond
pietro a grandi en jouant au basketball
qui ensuite non loin dé gagne aux
ambitions douteuses
j'ai vécu dans un milieu défavorisé j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui malheureusement ont
eu un mauvais parcours de vie
malheureusement ils n'ont pas eu l'aide
nécessaire puis moi si c'était
nécessaire là que je veux pour aider
monsieur moïse obtient un baccalauréat
en criminologie de psychologie et
interventions auprès des jeunes
il travaille maintenant au centre
jeunesse de montréal
ce que je trouve que c'est vraiment
défaire les faire et faire savoir que le
système est là pour les aider
c'est encore plus difficile depuis ce
soir du 20 septembre 2013 jetro jonathan
un autre ami se rendent au salon
funéraire une connaissance un membre de
gagne qui avait commandité des tournois
de basketball a été tué en prison quand
il s'éloigne du salon leur voiture est
suivi puis bloqué par deux
autopatrouilles monsieur moïse et du
côté passager
le procès de mon côté harris au moins il
dit au témoin suis vraiment surprise
comme une part dont j'apprends quelqu'un
qui dit et poignées la zone moi je me
retourne pas je me retourne n'est pas le
sien propre apprend décoller une ville
dort mais son genou sur masson manu il
met de la pression sur son genou bien
même thème du couple à l'ego l'âge
comment qui vous êtes vraiment sérieux
l'homme de 26 ans est sous le choc
d'autant plus qu'avant ce soir là il
n'avait jamais eu de démêlés avec la
justice
mais pressé comprendre ou soulèvent il
fera peut-être sur le capot du véhicule
quand je me retourne je crois qu'au fond
au niveau du visage
la tige ça m'a quand même quand même se
met au point le policier ne mettra plus
tard avoir donné un coup de poing
jonathan lui qui est menotté regardent
la scène impuissants vous été choqué
dans le vrai monde qui doit être choqué
de boixe ci doit être choqué mais c'est
juste que tu en vois tellement en année
en année que tu deviens habitué je me
senti comme un esclave disons je me suis
dit aux dépens de 6 hier je me suis posé
la question à savoir si c'est vraiment
ce que ça a été vraiment au québec
désabusé jetro et jonathan ne porte pas
plainte
quelques mois plus tard il tombe des
nues en apprenant que la police les
accuse un de menaces et d'intimidation
[Musique]
moi chaque fois que je mets faits
interpellés pour des raisons est
justifiée - c'est ça ça me cause
beaucoup de colère l'intervenant social
a vu mourir alors se transformer depuis
35 ans il a vu trop de jeunes noirs être
judiciariser sans raison valable
ils montrent un autre but si elles ne
sont pas payées le passage il bouscule
qu une personne dans la rue on dit ce
sont des gars qui a passé dans des
gaines dieu
pourtant quand c'est un jeune italien
qui fait qu'il ya le même type de
comportement on ne l'associent par la
mafia quand cette jeune québécois on ne
l'associent pas aux motards de simple
interpellation peuvent aboutir à des
accusations criminelles entrave par
exemple hiver dernier un juge a acquitté
un autre jeune noir accusé de voies de
fait contre un policier en concluant au
profilage racial
le profilage racial on le reconnaît
d'emblée qu'on ait des choses comme ça
comme organisation police ya là on n'est
pas content ça fait mal à l'organisation
ça fait mal à la population ça fait mal
aux citoyens pompe à la confiance des
gens c'est pas talaris donc on veut
vraiment être bannie
[Musique]
trois ans après l'arrestation et un
procès de quatre jours jetro et jonathan
sont équipés le tribunal conclut que les
policiers n'ont pas fait de profilage
racial mais fait usage de force
excessive et abusé de leurs pouvoirs
d'arrestation dans un acte répressif
illégale et inconstitutionnelle
l'accusée a subi une humiliation et une
atteinte à sa dignité
ce qu'on vit ces quelque chose d'atroce
c'est atroce parce que on est pros ni
pont ni pas vu de la même manière que le
monsieur madame tout le monde nouveau de
la société ils ont que la marge d'erreur
est très très minces qu'est ce que vous
souhaiteriez pour que ça s'améliore
qu'on essaie de tisser un lien entre les
jeunes et des policiers ou
on les démonte comme quoi que mais non
on est potes des animaux là